well hello my name is Don tipping I'm
here at seven seeds farm which is where
we run Siskiyou seeds where we grow
about 700 different open pollinated
organic fruits vegetables and herbs for
seed to distribute all over the world
and today I wanted to share how I start
tomatoes and peppers and eggplants a man
my greenhouse it's late March in Oregon
we started on these heat mats here which
are you can get at most garden centers
and they just boost up the temperature
so because our heat mat space is limited
I like to instead of starting my
tomatoes and pots
I started in these these little furrows
here and I'll demonstrate that in a
minute the equipment I'm using here is
we call this a 10 by 20 because it's ten
inches by 20 inches and then inside of
here I put it one that doesn't have all
these holes so it can hold soil and so
you can see that's what I've got here
this is filled with potting soil that we
made on the farm out of compost there'll
be a link to another video of how to
make potting soil in the comments but
pretty much it's composts and a little
bit of eggshells and help or you could
obviously by potting soil and why you
want to start these heat-loving crops on
heat mat is because they germinate quite
poorly in cool temperatures and right
now it's probably about 50 degrees
outside and these seeds one about 70 to
80 degrees so with an electric heat mat
I can ensure those temperatures so I'm
going to demonstrate one right now of
how I do this and we save pretty much
all around tomato seed I get these coin
envelopes before that and you can get
these at office supply store I wanted to
share a few little details of how I
label it tomatoes chestnut chocolate 18
I always write the year of
see to know how old it is because that
helps you with your seed saving so I
open the packet I put a little bit of
crease crease in there so as I tap it it
helps the seeds to line up and give me
more precision how I can tap them into
this little furrow I've made I'm
planting about 40 or 50 seeds in there
you get about an ounce of seed per
tomato plant you know I'm growing per
seed but if you're just growing for your
garden you're not necessarily concerned
with that I know stamp those in a little
bit and then I take some loose soil and
cover up my little furrow I'm aiming to
get them about a quarter inch deep I
found it's not actually super crucial
half inch to quarter inch works and then
on a popsicle stick I am going to write
chestnut chocolate for the variety name
I know it's a tomato and at this point
in my gardening life I can identify them
and I write the date on their March 27th
so if I'm feeling a little impatient
about the seeds coming up I know when I
planted them and I can tell if there's a
problem or not so I'm going to show you
in this tray here I planted Yankee bell
peppers so this is a little bit farther
along this was March 7th so 20 days ago
i seeded these in here on a heat map and
you can see some coming up here and they
you know obviously they were planted
quite close together you wouldn't want
to let them grow in these open flats
very long
it's more just something you use to get
them sprouted with heat so then I'm
going to separate them out one little
plant here and then this is the size I
like to use for peppers you can see I'm
filling up this little pot snug it in
there we'll do another one just so case
you missed anything it's pretty simple I
generally hold seedlings buy the leaves
instead of the stem because the plant
can regrow leaves it can't regrow it
stem in case you were a little bit rough
with it tuck it in there and that's it
these will grow up to be really nice
it starts in these and we'll plant them
out probably around June first
tomatoes I use something about twice as
big like something like this would work
well we also have some that are a little
deeper because tomatoes are just more
vigorous growing so you can see with
this method I can really concentrate
growing a lot of starts in a small
amount of space and you know make the
best use out of my heat mats so I hope
this was helpful and you learned
something that you're able to put into
action and improve your success at
starting tomatoes eggplants and peppers
from seeds you can use the same
technique for all of them and I'll put a
link again in the comments of our
website for accessing seed and we have a
free ebook on growing a hundred square
foot garden and all that you need to
know and the link to that will be in the
comments as well so I wish you all the
best and your growing efforts and may we
grow a world of good peace